what is up what is good how you living
how you feeling we have a very daunting
task as i'm sure everyone is
pouring in right now to the br app happy
saturday everybody it is hall of fame
weekend on thursday we had the las vegas
raiders stomping the jacksonville
jaguars just so that you know how much
of a degenerate i am i bet the raiders
minus two and a half were 1-0
on the nfl season already but what
happens is as every player that gets
honored into the hall of fame there's
this weird ranking thing that we all do
it's what we do as sports fans and
that's why we've got tear maker to help
us answer a very important question
everybody right now is saying that tom
brady is the goat
and i'll be honest it is hard to
disagree i don't think any player will
ever have seven super bowls let alone be
a quarterback and win seven super bowls
he's done it in multiple eras he's done
it with an offense with a defense he's
been a leader now two franchises it's
absurd
and so the question is
if we remove tom brady who is the second
goat that is the question we are looking
to answer today again
my name is adam lefkow to all the 33 out
there i love you a lot i hope you're
having an amazing day it is hot in new
york wherever you're watching i hope the
temperature is good too but who is
the second goat we are gonna try and
answer that question today because
we gotta say
tom brady is the first goat as you can
see so who is the second goat i have my
tears uh we have five tears and we have
20 athletes
that i have uh put as possible
goat tenders
now
there are people missing from this list
that hurt me
ed reed not being on this list hurt me
mean joe green not being on this list
jack lambert not being on this list uh
there there was a number of other
players i wasn't putting dan marino on
this list uh i just in no way
do i think that he's even in the
conversation uh also
if you comment i will try and get to as
many good comments as i can i have my
trusty uh bleacher report staff
on the survey for any good comments okay
so they'll be typing that in as we go uh
and right before we get started
big nick foles no brett favre
i will when i start talking about the
quarterbacks you will understand why i
do not have brett favre there big nick
foles uh shout out bdn um one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time um
however
and a lot of mvps
i think these guys are better and that's
what we do with these lists i'm going to
start off
very first
there was one name that i put on this
top 20 that was
completely oh i just got the br alert
now you know it's real
i'm i put one guy on this list solely
for my own satisfaction i do not believe
that he is the second best player of all
time but i want to get him his props and
it is this guy we are putting him in the
badass mfr's realm it is brian
dawkins my favorite athlete of all time
this is completely for me this is not
for anybody else but i did want to read
something about brian dawkins he is the
only safety in the history of the nfl
with 25 sacks 25 interceptions and 25
force fumbles he changed the position
and i literally came here just to give
him his props now i'll get into the rest
not done yet guys that i think are still
playing that still have more to prove
vintage ballers guys that
incredible stats incredible records but
i have a hard time comparing them to the
guys today
goat tenders is where i'm gonna put
anyone that has a chance to be named the
second goat and i will make that
distinction at the very end
let's start off with
you know what i'm gonna start off with
not done yet and i'm gonna put
my guy
an absolute legend
i'm gonna put aaron donald
into not done yet he's a current player
but i believe that he is already the
greatest defensive tackle of all time
and anyone that knows football knows
that you win games in the trenches just
a little perspective on aaron donald he
is already a three-time defensive player
of the year insanity he already almost
has a hundred sacks and 25 force fumbles
of the defensive tackle position he is a
seven time
first team all-pro
that means he's been the number one
defensive tackle for seven straight
years and he came into the league in
2014 which is eight years ago he's a
super bowl ring now and he is the only
defensive lineman
defensive tackle really non-edge pass
rusher with over 20 sacks in the season
aaron donald to me is the
greatest interior defensive lineman ever
already and i think that if the rams win
another super bowl this year
and he ends it like he did last year
messing up joe burrow and kind of going
this is the best player we've ever seen
i think he gets into
lt category and some of those other guys
so i'm putting him and not done yet
um mainly because i want him on here for
posterity in 10 years
all right let me see some comments here
uh robert
thermosillo aaron donald has lt numbers
as a defensive tackle exactly what i'm
saying um i i
i just i don't feel comfortable calling
him a goat tender yet uh but that's why
i put him in not done yet because it
feels
inevitable uh some other comments uh m
hainum saying walter payton listen
i just can't have that many running
backs on the list and for me that there
was two and you know what
let's put one of them up now
i am going to again put into the badass
mfers
this time
barry
mfing sanders barry m effing sanders
could never be
in the goat conversation because he
doesn't have the title rings
but at the same point
anyone that's ever watched football goes
number one
he's my favorite football player to
watch
and number two
man that dude had absolutely no help
we're talking no all line we're talking
no quarterbacks we're talking maybe
herman moore but even that was kind of
after it and like jim brown who we'll
get to later retired after nine seasons
just like calvin johnson because when
you get drafted by the lions unless
you're matt stafford and force a trade
you're kind of stuck there but just some
perspective on barry sanders six time
all-pro one of the rare
running back mvps that we've ever seen
two-time offensive player of the year
99 touchdowns a little bit more than 15
000 rushing yards the greatest youtube
athlete ever
uh barry sanders
is a badass mfer
but unfortunately he can't be my goat
tender great comment here by cajun baby
ladainian tomlinson has a much better
career than barry sanders
the only reason that i would put barry
over lt
is that lt was on some of the best teams
that we've seen the nfl those chargers
teams were some of the most talented
most
underwhelming teams the playoff we've
ever seen but i agree with you that era
of lt and priest homes the running backs
were going nuts um and barry sanders
also had you know a 2 000 yard rushing
season but
uh you
it's hard for me i just i didn't want
too many running backs on this list
because i think in the grand scheme of
things other positions have more
importance
but barry's my guy
okay we got two comments here ryan
nicholas saying ed reed should be on
here i agree i had to keep it to 20.
believe me i look man i got i got larry
allen on here we got some interesting
guys but the comments that
i knew i was gonna get
charles drew brees not being on this
list is possibly the most disrespectful
thing of all time blake preston lefko
you've always been a saints he s saints
hater no brees but mahomes
let's put mahomes
on the not done yet
because
i cannot do a list in which a guy that
came in and won an mvp and then a super
bowl in his first two years like patrick
mahomes will be in this conversation but
he's not
in the conversation for goat right now
but i do believe that he is the most
talented quarterback of all time which
is what i will say to get into this
breeze conversation
i'll admit it
i'm a drew brees hater
i think that drew brees had sean payton
for the entirety of his career and sean
payton can make guys like taysom hill
and jameis winston look good
i think that
i know that they drafted marcus colston
late but he was a heck of a player
um i think they've had good offensive
line play i think that drew brees is
undoubtedly a top quarterback of all
time
he is not better than aaron rodgers
he has one ring
he has one ring
and so i cannot put him over montana and
bradshaw who have four
because
i mean i do not want to make this whole
video about how drew brees
always did not deliver in the playoffs
okay
okay i'm done
uh most 5000 seasons ever breeze got
five no one else has two i mean matt
stafford got a few but it's also an era
thing like
they it was a different game we are not
turning this into a drew brees thing he
is not one of the best players of all
time he is not have the best arm it was
constantly an issue late in the season
he's really good and accurate and he's a
great game manager okay
he's alex smith on steroids and i'm done
uh petufo saying t.o played super bowl
with a broken leg and still destroyed
the patriots defense
true but the problem is
is when you get into
these guys i'm putting another badass
mfr randy moss
t.o is not better
fly teo is not better than jerry rice or
randy moss in terms of
winning super bowls accomplishing things
in the playoffs i am an eagles fan what
teo did was amazing he is unconscionable
but i cannot call him
i cannot call him the goat randy moss
four-time all-pro
set the nfl world on fire unlike any
other wide receiver
when push comes to shove if i'm building
a team i am taking randy moss and jerry
rice as my two wide receivers
if i'm going to be honest with everyone
in here right now thank you blade brown
rainy moss is a bad mf er
i think randy moss is one of the baddest
mfrs to ever play
i personally if i was building a team
would take randy moss over jerry rice
he is taller i believe that he is faster
i believe that he was more dominant and
i believe that he instilled more fear
and i think the thing about jerry rice
and joe montana and a lot of those guys
charles haley
they also had bill walsh which you know
look that was the big thing about brady
is he had belichick but then he goes and
wins one with non-belichick and now that
storyline is gone montana and rice do
not have that luxury but uh randy moss
to me is one of my favorite athletes of
all time when he fake pulled his pants
down at lambeau and joe buck acted as
though he gave the finger to everybody i
still thought it was great uh you know
all of his lines randy moss was such a
badass mfr he was one of those guys
there was this era where everyone kept
going to the raiders that was a badass
mfr warren sapp went to the raiders he
could be on this list um randy moss went
to the raiders and it was just a
collection of badass mfr's rainy moss is
one of my favorite players of all time
let me get to some comments really quick
um
mario breeze was great but not top tier
mac jones for rookie of the year writes
antonio brown he won a ring carried the
steelers
i've been thinking a lot about him this
off season how
his escapades these last two years
have completely ruined the fact that he
had an absolute dominant
seven to eight year run where big ben
could literally throw it anywhere and he
was coming down with it antonio brown
was amazing but again i'm not putting
antonio brown over t.o and i didn't put
t.o on this list so i can't put antonio
brown into this cajun baby randy moss
made dante culpepper look like tb12
listen man when it was dante and nate
burlson out there and randy moss and
robert smith in the backfield and jim
klein saucer those vikings teams were
awesome uh we have a few comments here
for calvin johnson torres saying calvin
johnson blue stuck calvin johnson was
moss on steroids jack would you take t
over calvin johnson
calvin johnson
um
was
freaking insane
insane
if calvin johnson was the first time
that many of us ever watched a football
game and the announcers would circle
triple coverage
on a wide receiver
i think that when i get into goat lists
so this is not best wide receiver list
this is a goat debate
calvin johnson's lack of playoff
anything
lack of playoff anything
prevents him from being discussed as a
goat
you know it's uh
it's look larry fitzgerald what he did
in the playoffs
what he did like puts him a little bit
over calvin but calvin to me is a
creative player calvin was the most
incredible player wide receiver i've
seen austin t saying andre johnson was
better than calvin we're getting into a
wide receiver debate and i'm going to
put my first player into the goat
tenders
and that's jerry rice
jerry rice is officially our first
player that has a chance of being named
second goat
randy moss has i mean excuse me jerry
rice has almost 23 000 receiving yards
almost 200 touchdowns which is insane he
had 10 rushing touchdowns he was an
offensive player of the year he won a
super bowl mvp
he was four for four in the super bowl
with four super bowl rings
he leads all time in receptions
receiving yards receiving touchdowns and
yards from scrimmage so that includes
all the running backs as well
he played 29 playoff games and caught 22
touchdowns and had eight
touchdowns in super bowls
i believe that he is
up there
with
john stockton in the nba
in terms of leading in statistical
categories that i never believe will be
touched i don't believe stockton's
assist will ever be touched i don't
think jerry rice's receiving yards will
ever be touched he is undoubtedly the
runaway winner when you look at
accomplishments and stats as the
greatest and most accomplished wide
receiver of all time
randy moss t.o calvin johnson
i believe all of them are more talented
but i think when it comes to the goat
there's a lot of talented quarterbacks
that were more talented than tom brady
aaron rodgers is more talented dan
marino is more talented patrick mahomes
is definitely more talented
but tom brady was consistent excellence
over decades and that's what jerry rice
was even those last few years in oakland
he was unbelievable
jerry rice
is a goat tender he is up for second
goat dee faversa saying jerry rice is
the greatest of all time
uh austin t jerry rice you stick them on
his hands automatic elimination moss
over rice
i mean
this is also though an era before like
advanced training you know what i mean
and like
people using protein like jerry rice was
walking up and down a hill uh and also
i'm just gonna be honest having used nfl
players gloves before
how is that not stickum them
go to your backyard go and go and get a
nice pair of gloves and you're going to
be like
it's it's stikum it's just in gloves it
it's so i i i like that comment though
that was great uh philly's specialty
rice had montana and young though that
has to be mentioned philly's specialty
you're getting ahead of me when it comes
time to pick the second goat
that will be a nugget that is used
because help around you is big pj castro
tony gonzalez not even mentioned tony
gonzalez great tight end
had a few great years with the chiefs um
phew he had a very long time with the
chiefs i don't know if tony gonzalez is
my best tight end of all time
because i think gronk was a much better
blocker than tony uh also shout out my
guy travis kelsey
you got to show off his rookie card
really quick um
and but i would also say that uh shannon
sharp deserves love if i'm being real
shannon was a beast but i love tony
gonzalez uh he was a mismatch for so
long he felt like he was taller than
everybody
all right so let's now go
uh i'm gonna enter i'm gonna get rid of
this right now
we're putting terry bradshaw on the
vintage ballers
terry bradshaw
one time all pro he did win an mvp which
not everyone on this list won an mvp
he was a four-time super bowl winner
he was on the
all-1970s team but it was a different
game
for his career 212 touchdowns 210
interceptions and if we're being honest
i would probably i probably should have
put mean joe green on this list or jack
lambert on this list instead of terry
bradshaw but in goat debates he won an
mvp he has four super bowl mvps but i'll
just be honest i do not believe that he
is nearly talented as the rest of this
as the rest of these guys uh and i also
think that
it's tough i'm gonna do it again i'm
gonna go dick buckus uh into the vintage
ballers as well dick butkus um
literally was feared for two decades for
the 60s and 70s
he averaged more interceptions per year
than ray lewis um he was a five-time
all-pro he won he was on the all 60s and
70s team and he was a two dime defensive
player of the year but if you put him in
today's game
austin eckler would make him look stupid
that's just the facts it was a different
game it was
a gap b-gap i'm gonna punish you who can
handle punishment longer but i just need
to say that on a goat list
he is up there for top names for goat
names
as a child being allowed to say the
words dick butt kiss
is one of the funniest things i've ever
been able to experience in my life but
also
i mean what what a name
but dick butkus i'm gonna put him in the
vintage ballers
black george saying he's using the j.j
redick here no disrespect buckets was
playing against firemen and plumbers and
i'm just going to say that i think
firemen are dope and at this point
man plumbers
i mean you could go on amazon and get
some stuff do you really need a plumber
like you really need to clog up your
things if you're calling a plumber like
you really need to be embarrassed if
you're calling a plumber
i'm going to finish off the vintage
ballers
and where is this old man there he is
johnny united
johnny unitas
is tough because
he was peyton manning before peyton
manning
johnny unitas was the first quarterback
to go on the field and call plays
himself
johnny unitas was the smartest guy in
his era the the best athlete of his era
the strongest the best arm of his era
and what he did with that baltimore
colts franchise
uh was insanity
um
i had a chance when i worked in
louisville he went to louisville to see
a bunch of his statues and read a lot
about him
he's he is a guy that was truly before
his time
um and i believe that he is a goat
a true goat
one of the greatest of all time he made
my top six quarterbacks to even make
this list over dan marino over brett
favre
over uh drew brees the guys that we were
saying earlier
but
i i am a little bit like black george
where it's like i'm comparing eras and
i don't i i feel like a guy like patrick
mahomes could go back to that day and
dominate now i don't know how united's
going to do but i wanted to give a lot
of great respects to as ssj4 drew says
the first great qb
johnny u he's the reason that the game
is even obsessed with the forward pass
i mean before then you got quarterbacks
thrown on it like they're serving
meals
you know what i mean
uh black george without johnny you the
nfl would look like navy versus georgia
tech a hundred percent agree
um
and
uh ssj4 drew gladshaw wouldn't shouldn't
sniff a top 10 qb list let alone a goat
list listen bro when you got four super
bowl rings you need we need to have a
discussion about you and maybe the
discussion is you shouldn't be on here
but he was the man also terry bradshaw
the charles barkley of the nfl in terms
of being able to go on and say weird
things and people laugh it's a pretty
awesome italian stallion saying butkus
is better than ray lewis
and i'm gonna put ray lewis now
in the badass
mf
ray lewis
i'll just speak from the heart first
there was something about
turning on a monday night football game
and seeing ray lewis with his enormous
shoulders and it looked like his head
was like burrowed in it
yelling and screaming his entrance was
the closest that we in the modern era
have seen to roman gladiators entering
the coliseum
his i interned at nfl network at nfl
films when i was in high school
and i had a few days where i was able to
go into the vault and request any
footage of any game to watch
and i requested ray lewis miked up
and i sat there for two hours
listening to a man preach
and threaten people at the same time
what god will bestow upon you is the
wrath of the ravens the raven's defense
was so good
that the last few years the ravens
defense has been average and when you
turn on a ravens game you still go man
that ravens defense because it's all
because of ray lewis again
i wish i got ed reed on this list too ed
reed is one of my favorite safeties all
time that era of dawkins ed reed
palamalu was disgusting
disgusting
but
ray lewis was the leader and i tried to
focus on leaders for this list
ray lewis over 2 000 tackles the only
player in the history of the nfl with 40
sacks and 30 interceptions a three-time
defensive player of the year like aaron
donald that shows you how freaking
special aaron donald is
he left
on the super bowl
he beat the niners he retired we have a
few guys on this list that did that and
i really think it kind of changes how we
remember them he led baltimore in
tackles 14 of 17 seasons
and that 2000 defense he's got two super
bowl rings that 2000 defense that he led
didn't allow a thousand yards
in the in rushing yards
the whole year they let up 970 rushing
yards and 165 points
they they let up like six points every
game it was disgusting but ray lewis a
badass mfer
um
coffee snob comparing bradshaw to
barkley from a comedy point of view is
the most expect disrespectful thing i've
ever heard it's a different level of
comedy coffee snout i'm talking about
the ability to get away with saying
things but barkley is like dave
chappelle and terry bradshaw is like
um get her done
larry the cable guy very very different
uh levels of comedy but the ability to
say things for laughter uh facts with a
ph saying rey was an absolute machine mr
banks terry bradshaw as trent dilfer
with no salary cap
s burke ray lewis is the second greatest
defensive player of all time
of all time
well i am going to add one to the goat
tender list
and that is going to be that man
lt
lawrence freaking tender
my man lawrence taylor
won defensive player of the year as a
rookie
imagine coming into the nfl and
destroying it to the level where they're
like yeah you're the best defensive
player here
in
1986 he did something that we have never
seen before
1986
lawrence taylor
has 20 and a half sacks
wins defensive player of the year
wins mvp of the
nfl and wins the super bowl
insanity he's got two super bowl rings
one with phil sims one with jeff
hostetler and bill belichick has said
he is the goat
bill belichick has said and again he
coached him
he is the goat 142 sacks an incredible
cameo on any given sunday lawrence
taylor one of the scariest dudes ever if
i read a blind side if you've ever read
blindside
it literally talks about how bill walsh
and the nfl had to change the way they
looked at left tackles because of
lawrence taylor
that before him they were road grading
plodding big run pushers and after him
it was all about feet
lawrence taylor is the reason we got
jonathan ogden
lawrence taylor is the reason that we
got walter jones and all of the best
left tackles of all time it all happened
out of necessity to stop him
lawrence taylor undoubtedly a contender
for second goat behind tom brady
uh some other comments here right now
lillian's king adam vinatieri i thought
about putting him on here i'm not even
lying i thought about putting adam
vinatieri on there uh but after a while
i was like i can't knock off one of
these other guys i mean look who's on
the bottom right now like look who we
still have
um
uh big town mourinho is better than
elway period
not only do i disagree with you
vehemently
i'm putting elway as a goat tender
i am and i know this might come shocking
to some of you
you guys need to understand that john
elway was the most physically gifted
quarterback his entire freaking career
and we all saw him at the very end
winning two super bowls and leading the
way with terrell davis the reason that i
put him as a goat tender is because
there are other quarterbacks that i want
to put on there i'm gonna do it right
now peyton manning
he is a goat tender for second goat and
they both have two super bowls and i
believe that elway was more physically
talented than peyton manning but i
believe that peyton manning was one of
the greatest if not the greatest
orchestrators composers maestros of of
super bowl quality football we've ever
seen but i just want to say that john
elway
i cannot begin to explain to the younger
generation how physically talented he
was that this man could throw it as far
as josh allen and patrick mahomes
and
what a gifted leader an absolute baller
uh i love i love john elway
peyton manning let me just get into him
peyton manning
seven time all pro
super bowl mvp two-time super bowl
winner over 72 000 passing yards his
famed 2013 season he had 55 touchdowns
it was as if the rest of the nfl should
give up wes welker here
demarius thomas there eric decker
wherever i think he was on the team
but i think the two stats that are crazy
about peyton manning is number one
he is our only in the nfl
five time mvp winner
five times
this man was the mvp
second stat that was crazy about peyton
manning
he won
68
of the games that he played
in 10 games more often than not he was
winning seven
that's disgusting think about how bad
that indie defense was for a long time
think about how he was able to go from
marvin harrison to reggie wayne from
edrin james to joseph adai
offensive line issues different coaches
didn't matter
peyton manning was getting it done
there are two players that i know that
bill belichick had to game for the game
plan for the most ed reed and peyton
manning peyton manning is amazing ssj
peyton manning is the regular season
goat
you might be right because
i felt bad for him man ty law and lawyer
malloy and those patriots teams had his
number
one stepper elway is the most gifted
gifted athlete ever could have been a
baseball hall of famer too i
i'll tell you never sleep on uh elway
samwell's vinatari could have knocked
off bradshaw easily maybe
sally b
lt the only defensive player to be the
best player on multiple super bowl teams
interesting because i would agree with
you that even tom brady wasn't the best
player on a lot of his teams defensive
line won the buck super bowl
his defense won him a lot of those first
super bowls he had a lot to do with the
middle ones but i think that's a very
interesting point
um
dropping dimes emmett smith better than
barry sanders unfortunately
i disagree and part of the reason is
this guy
larry allen
i am putting him as
a badass
mfr
the stories about larry allen i had to
get him on this list
this man was benching nearly a ton
i i'm a believer that while troy aikman
is great
and michael irvin
was great
and emmitt smith was awesome
i believe that for the 90s the cowboys
had the scariest man
in the nfl
his strength is unparalleled i do not
believe it's ever been matched his speed
was incredible
he controlled the middle of the
defensive line for like a decade
all decade guy
john madden's favorite player
he is the andre the giant of the nfl and
i just wanted to give him some respect
because a lot of these great offenses
were really a function of
great offensive lines and i needed to
get one on here i could have gone
anthony munoz i could have gone jonathan
ogden i went larry allen because the
fear he created but damn jonathan ogden
was insane
uh akin of spot jake cutler is not a
goat
okay hot take hot take alex marr i get
the vinatari love but i would say justin
tucker is the best kicker of all time
i'll just say this that's all fair and
good you can kick all the 60 yard field
goals you want and you can you can win a
lot of regular season games
until you hit
a super bowl game-winning kick another
super bowl game-winning kick
a kick in the snow to send you to the
super bowl adam vinatieri has hit the
most clutch kicks of all time and i take
clutchness over kick power any day
that's just my point
i am seeing a few comments vegan hippie
aaron rodgers is the most talented ever
and has four mvps
and then josh factor roger's most gifted
quarterback to ever play
it's a fact
and i'm going to put
aaron rodgers
not done yet to cop out to cop out
it's a cop out
rodgers has four mvps
aaron rodgers has one super bowl
aaron rodgers went to peru and did
ayahuasca and came back and won two more
mvps
my man is in touch with his with his chi
my man is seeing colors and tasting
sounds
my man is having
eyeball angels fly down and tell him
allow devante adams to leave
focus on your young wide receiving core
like alan lazard
aaron rodgers
to me is already in the bad ass mfr's
aaron rodgers to me
if he wins another super bowl is a true
goat tender because i believe he is the
only guy
i believe that him and mahomes
and josh allen
dan this new generation is amazing i was
going to say justin herbert too but they
haven't done it long enough aaron
rodgers is the closest we've seen to
john elway but his ability to break down
defenses with his eyes is up there the
crazy thing about aaron rodgers is his
touchdown to interception ratio is so
much better than everybody else and
that's the reason i had him over farv is
that he barely throws interceptions and
he had an incredible run for a super
bowl in 2011. my only thing is
man
these last few years losing to the 49ers
is just hard to get out of my head but i
think aaron rodgers has been the best
quarterback in the nfl for a while
um even these last few years where i
would have taken my homes he won mvp but
aaron rodgers is a bad man as steven a
and night i'll say but he's in the not
done yet all three of those guys they
win another title this gets really
really interesting uh jerry's universe
larry allen was the best player on those
early 90s cowboys team that's exactly
why i put him in there jerry's universe
i'm glad you see it like i do peanut
emma smith is one of the most ordered
players of all time i got into a yelling
match with him
at uh the eagles super bowl because the
eagles fans were booing him so i'm not
the biggest emmitt smith fan but i also
did get drunk with him uh on a lefko
show podcast later on and he redeemed
himself so i'm not going to call him the
most overrated player of all time but
you wrote one of okay
um
we already read that pet peyton manning
is the regular season goat uh facts
could you guys get mahomes and allen are
the new elways i could totally see that
tieber let's not forget adam vinatieri
threw a touchdown in 2004 he should be
on this list i love that you're fighting
for him and 49er gal montana is the
greatest of all time end of discussion i
am putting him in the goat tenders so we
have two 49ers
in the goat tenders joe montana
three-time all-pro
three-time super bowl mvp so the only
one that he didn't win went to the other
goat tender jerry rice
all 80s team
two-time mvp which is really solid
4-0 in super bowls
this is an interesting step for two
reasons joe montana in super bowls 11
touchdowns
zero interceptions
it's interesting for the first point
because you're going man this guy was
perfect in every super bowl
the weird thing is though remember what
he did in the bengal super bowl he threw
like four or five that means he averaged
like one or two touchdowns in the other
super bowls
joe montana though is
i think was the goat
the true goat for
20 years
and then
peyton manning started doing what he was
doing
and tom brady started doing what he was
doing and it changed the conversation i
think joe montana is one of the most
beloved and respected guys i love his
son nikki he's a great dude
but
what joe montana also had was what joe
barrow is being acclaimed for right now
which is being cool under pressure
joe montana was smooth as silk
and i'll get to the to the negative
stuff later ricky waters and all i can
remember is chiefs joe montana that's
what happens man when you're younger you
start see like there are people out
there that only know vikings brett favre
or jet spread farf and that's just weird
uh jake the snake saying ryan rice and
montana were ass compared to moss and
brady hot take hot take
uh jay flores just moved rogers to
second good already ready even though
he's not done
and tad hg saying jim brown is the goat
and he is going
into my goat tenders
jim brown
is the greatest lacrosse player of all
time
the reason that you see lacrosse guys do
this
is because jim brown used to put it at
syracuse on his chest
and people would swipe at him and they
couldn't get it out of his hands because
he was so big that he would just run
down he's the greatest lacrosse player
of all time but jim brown
in nine years
over 12 000 rushing yards 126
touchdowns
he retired at the age of 29 so him and
barry sanders
are very close
he went to the pro bowl
every single year of his career nine for
nine
he averaged
5.2 yards per carry he is the wilt
chamberlain of the nfl to where it it's
like dropping shaq in 1960s basketball
he led the nfl in rushing yards
if it's nine years eight times
there was no other running back in the
history of the nfl that has done it more
than four i think adrian peterson's up
there at four
but this was the stat that was freaking
crazy to me about jim brown
he played nine years
he won three mvps
that means 33 percent of the time jim
brown won mvp and you know how mvp works
they always end up giving it to somebody
else they probably could have given it
to him six years out of the nine but jim
brown what he did on the field what he
did off the field but this is mainly on
the field uh
absolute stud and a lot like barry
sanders a lot like calvin johnson what
if he played 15 what if he did a brady
and played 20 but he became a movie star
but jim brown undoubtedly a goat
extreme jim brown is the second goat
bottom line champ wrote jim brown is
like a literal god that second goat spot
is his for sure uh spliff passer jim
brown easily the best actor
on the list uh payton's pretty good
lawrence taylor we've seen in a few
really good things i've never seen uh
terry bradshaw i'm sure has acted i bet
you dick dick buttkiss was in the movie
uh i'll i'll just tell pat mahomes he
ain't got that acting gene
he just does not
uh but there's a few other guys down
here that i think uh could be so jay
grooks is making a suggestion elway and
ray lewis should be swapped
saying that i should put ray lewis as a
goat tender and john elway is a badass
m.f
i'll think about it i'll think about i'm
going to listen to you guys
uh josh factor saying ernie davis man
talking about cues got to give him a
shout out 44
44.
ernie davis bad man bad man
john green steve young made you realize
joe montana wasn't as great as you think
that's what's interesting man
but it did make you realize that bill
walsh is and because we have niners
we're putting one of the baddest
mfers ever
ronnie lot
ca2dc
what about ronnie lot cut off part of
his finger to stay in the game that is
why ronnie lott is one of the bad at
most badass mfs ever i just want to
state this for the record
i love my badass mfrs now that i'm
looking at it
dawkins barry sanders moss
lewis larry allen and ronnie lot
yo
that three on three would get bloody
ronnie lot
played 192 games very long time for his
safety very long time
um
63 interceptions third all time
he played in 20 playoff games and had
nine picks and two touchdowns man he was
effective when it mattered
um
he is one of only two players the other
one is mean joe green who could have
been on this list as a badass mfr
with four super bowl rings
and ten pro bowls
ronnie lott was the heartbeat of that
defense
four super bowl rings
but
ronnie a lot it's a different era it
would stink if he played today because
he wouldn't be able to lay the wood uh
x-file saying how is dawkins on there
and ed reed is not x-file i said in the
very beginning the only thing i did for
my own personal thing was was brian
dawkins he's my favorite athlete of all
time i know i got one over here
i know i got a brian dawkins card
um i even met ed reid last week and he
was great but
listen ed reed is sensational uh ed reed
i could have put ed reed over terry
bradshaw in a second to be honest but um
i i was like you know what
i already got ray lewis and i want the
leader of the team not ed reed and i
thought the same thing about the niners
but i can't keep off montana or rice
it's just not possible um
and you know what peanut peanut is
actually making a great comment right
now ronnie was a great
lock down corner before he was a goat
safety ronnie lott um to me is truly one
of the greatest
nfl players of all time
i love ronnie a lot i love hard-hitting
safeties
rick de vero
jim brown was not the best actor brett
favre in something about mary
franco beans frank and beans
i love him uh dwayne irvin saying
reggie white was a man amongst boys
i'm putting him in the badass mfr list
reggie white had 12
double-digit sack seasons
he had 198 sacks second all-time only
behind bruce smith
i couldn't put bruce smith on here i'm
not putting somebody that lost four
super bowls on here just not
uh two dime defensive player of the year
reggie white
super bowl ring with the packers i
remember when he was on the eagles man
and it was
uh that defense that 91 eagles defense
was insane with him and jerome brown
13 all pros and what's even crazier is
he spent a few years in the usfl where
he was the best player in that league
reggie white one of the baddest dudes
ever but also
i think the reason why you see prayer
circles at the end of games he was known
as the minister of defense an incredible
player a true leader
absolutely beloved died way too soon but
reggie white amazing
um
italian stallion so all these 49ers are
goats yet none of them benefited from
each other a hundred percent and that
will come down to it but let me just get
this in here
dion sanders
i am putting him
as a goat tender
i am
deion sanders played 188 games
even though he was barely challenged
because he was the nastiest corner ever
he still had
58 interceptions excuse me 53
interceptions this man retired for a few
years
played
641 major league baseball games
and then came back to the nfl
and played
cornerback and safety mainly cornerback
until the age of 38.
and i'm willing to argue here right now
that i think it's more impressive to
play cornerback at 38 than it is to play
quarterback at 45.
it's just insane
uh dion sanders
was a six-time all-pro
all-90s
two-time super bowl winner
cowboys niners won a defensive player of
the year and here's what's wild about
dion sanders
he scored
nine touchdowns from interceptions
he scored
six touchdowns from punt returns he
scored three touchdowns from kick
returns he scored three touchdowns
receiving it as a wide receiver he
scored one touchdown as a fumble
recovery and he scored one touchdown
running the football
nobody scored the ball in more different
ways than dion sanders
he was somebody that defen offenses had
to cut off half the field
to avoid
that
he truly m he truly changed the game
and
one of the coolest athletes in the
history in the nfl
so here is what i have for my list
we have seven goat contenders that have
a chance to be named the second goat
as again
tom brady is the goat we are saying that
because it is hall of fame weekend
but one of these players
needs to be named
the second goat
how is there a category called bad ass
mf and prime isn't in it because he is
up for second goat okay
i want to take this time
i
i
would love for you guys to uh comment
right now
um i'm going to ask my bleacher report
crew just give me an overall vibe
what were the most of the comments for
uh what are we saying
um
[Music]
and what i'm going to do
is i'm going to talk this out i'm going
to who wants to be a millionaire
so i'm hearing from my my my staff my
crack staff
mostly jim brown
extreme saying yep no second goat don't
do it left go leave the second goat
empty
now we didn't come here and spend all
this time to leave it empty
i'm going to say
that
first and foremost
i think that jerry rice is truly up for
second goat because his statistics are
insane
because of that
and because of bill walsh
who i think is the greatest offensive
mind ever
i am removing
joe montana
from second goat okay so he doesn't have
a chance there's six left
i also believe
that peyton manning
had more impact on the game
than john elway
and i also believe that because they
both have two super bowls it's even
of eliminating john elway
so i've eliminated two of the
quarterbacks so we have a wide receiver
a pass rusher a quarterback a running
back and a do everything corner left
i'm going to move them out of respect
john elway
i'm going to move him to badass mfors
i'm going to move joe montana to bad
smfers so that it's
in there
look at this list
it is a badass list
you have a five-time mvp in peyton
manning you have a three-time mvp even
though he only played nine years jim
brown you have dion sanders who did
everything
you have laura who she was put fear into
people you have lawrence taylor who's
one of the most dominant
gnarly bill belichick calls him the goat
and then you have jerry rice who runs
every statistical category
because tom brady is the goat and i
don't feel like doing this much
quarterback stuff i'm moving peyton
manning down
i can't move him down
just know that peyton manning
has been eliminated
torres
lawrence taylor changed how offenses
look at football done
ola very rice and it's not close
jay grooks from that list it's gotta be
jim brown
jamie willis saying jim brown is the
goat his linemen had to block with their
forearms couldn't even hold
and tv's tom selleck saying i miss left
going local news here and left in
louisville
i might go back there later this month
but i will tell you that i do not miss
doing local news
i am ready to make my decision
everybody at home on their phones
drumroll please
and with
the official
first ever
second goat
tier maker rankings
i
adam lefkow
and going to crown
not jerry rice
not cherry rice
not jerry rice
i am going to crown
not peyton manning
not peyton manning
i am going to crown
not lawrence taylor
this is who it's between
i'm not even kidding jim brown and
dionne sanders
my goat
second goat
i'm not gonna lie i came in here really
wanting to pick deion sanders but i read
all that stuff about jim brown and now
i'm like damn
it's my list
i am naming dion sanders the second goat
ever behind tom brady
much love to jim brown let me put all
these dudes back on the goat tender list
because they deserve to be up there but
i am making dion sanders the second goat
of all time i just think it is way too
hard to play the cornerback position i
think he changed the game i think the
way that he got money the way that he
was intercepted the style the high kicks
the moving it down dion sanders
prime time
is the second goat of all time he made
the game so much more joyful um but i i
just think the corner wreck position's
really really hard and i think dion
sanders is the second goat
i had a blast doing this i have no idea
if the comment section is killing me
right now but thank you to everybody
that commented and joined in thanks to
everybody uh at bleacher report for
helping make this possible i've never
done it before uh it's a very fun time i
think it's a great distraction from what
i believe is the worst hall of fame
class to ever get inducted and it's
going in tonight so while all of you
tony beselli fans are going nuts tonight
argue with your friends about who the
second goat is of all time behind tom
brady i had a great time hit me up on
social at adam lefkow hit me up on
twitter let me know what you think i'm
always happy to debate this stuff it's a
blast but appreciate you everybody have
a great day and that is my second goat
prime time
oh yeah